what we're going to do in this video is
tackle some word problems involving
ratios
so here we're told that yoda soda is the
intergalactic party drink that will have
all of your friends saying um good this
is
you are throwing a party and you need
five liters of yoda soda for every 12
guests
if you have 36 guests how many liters of
yoda soda do you need so pause this
video and try to figure it out on your
own
well they tell us the ratio of liters of
soda to number of guests so you need
five
it's a five liters for every 12 guests
is the ratio
but we want to have 36 guests so
if the ratio is 5 liters of soda for
every 12 guests but we're in a situation
where we have 36 guests so this is three
times as many guests we're gonna need
three times as many liters of soda so
three times five is fifteen
five to twelve five liters for twelve
guests or four five liters for every 12
guests is the same thing as 15 liters
for every 36 guests so to answer that
question how many liters do you need you
need 15 liters let's do another one of
these
here we just have a picture of a bunch
of fish in a tank and it says there are
eight big fish for every blank small
fish and then it says there are four big
fish for every blank small fish so pause
this video again and see if you can work
through this
all right so let's just count the big
fish first
so there's one two three let me see
count this way one two three four five
six seven eight so in this tank there
actually are eight big fish and so let's
see how many small fish there are
there's one two three four five six
seven eight nine
ten small fish
so in the tank for every eight big fish
which you see in red there are ten small
fish
but here it says there are four big fish
for every blank small fish so what would
that be
well one way to think about it is we
have half as many fish we are half as
many big fish so we divided by two so
we're going to have half as many small
fish so we're gonna divide by two so for
every four big fish there are five small
fish and one way to think about it you
could divide the fish evenly into two
groups right over here so let's see if
we can capture
so if you could have
this is
if i divide it like that here i have one
two three four big fish and one two
three four five small fish then in this
group i have one two three four big fish
and one two three four five small fish
so every four big fish there are five
small fish these are equivalent ratios
let's keep going
so here we're told an ice cream shop
uses the following ingredients to make
one sundae
so they use two scoops of ice cream four
spoonfuls of sprinkles two tablespoons
of whipped cream how many sundaes did
the shop make if they used 32 spoonfuls
of sprinkles so pause the video and try
to think about it
so there's a couple of ways to think
about it
here it says let's see we're talking
about sprinkles so that's what's
relevant here four spoonfuls for every
one sunday so we could say that there so
the ratio of spoonfuls to sundays is
four to one
four spoonfuls
spoon
fulls of sprinkles let me write this way
let me write sprinkles
sprinkles how many spoonfuls
how many spoonfuls per
sunday
but here we're talking about using 32
spoonfuls of sprinkles so that is eight
times as many so you're going to be able
to use create eight times as many
sundaes so you're going to have 32
spoonfuls of sprinkles for every eight
sundays so how many sundays did the shop
make well they made eight
let's do one last example
at a dog park there are 10 black dogs 5
brown dogs 2 white dogs and 12
multi-colored dogs
for every one brown dog there are two
blank dogs pause the video and figure
out what goes in this blank
all right so let's see there's five
brown dogs for every ten black dogs five
brown dogs for every two white dogs and
five brown dogs for every 12
multicolored dogs but here you're saying
for every one brown dog there are two
blank dogs
so what type of dog is their ratio so
for every brown dog there's twice as
many of that type of dog
well here we see for every five brown
dogs
there are 10
black dogs so one way to think about it
the number of black dogs is always going
to be twice the number of brown dogs
so for every one brown dog there would
be two
two
black
two black dogs one way to think about it
the ratio between brown dogs and black
dogs and it's kind of counterintuitive i
use the wrong colors here i should use
brown and black so let me do that
so the ratio of brown to black is five
brown dogs for every 10
10 black dogs or if you divide both of
these numbers by five you would get one
one brown dog for every two
for every two black dogs and that's
exactly what this statement is saying